Good
morning- thank you for being
here today my name's remember
Blanca Rubio and I am proud to
represent the city of
convenience ina I wanna thank
you all for participating today
as chair of the assembly select
committee on domestic violence
and on behalf of my fellow
committee members thank you to
everyone for being a part of
these important conversations
today I am especially grateful
to the city of convene an for
hosting us and the server
writers for participating as
panelists and part of the
resource fair. The theme of
this hearing centers on the
notion that domestic violence-
and intimate partner violence
affects people of all races
gender sexual orientations age
groups and social economic
statuses I'm are three panel
panels will highlight best
practices for law enforcement
local resources and how we can
specifically support the B. T.
R. Q. plus survivors were as-
LGBTQ plus as for lesbian gay
bisexual Trask transgender
transsexual queer questioning
intersects a special ally and
sexual before we begin with
calls I would like to share
some statistics. Provide
contact to the urgency of topic.
Day on average twenty four
people per minute are victims
of rape physical violence or
stocking by an intimate partner
in the United States. More than
twelve million women and men
over the course of a year. Let
me just be really clear I. This
is my third year and the
assembly and- being part of the
domestic violence on committee
and when we have these
conversations it's been very
eye opening for me when we talk
about the mystic violence that
everyone really it just
automatically assumes that the
victim is a female. Now I want
to make clear that victims are
everywhere not just females we
have males are victims as well
and as I stated there's a list
of other folks that are victims
and the part- died really
frustrates me is the
conversation about children-
somewhere I read that- when
there's an issue with the
mystic violence the statistic
automatically goes either to
the victim. Or the perpetrator
but if a child is involved in
that that householder an
altercation the children are
not designated as domestic
violence victims so the
statistics are skewed in my
opinion because yes domestic
violence a affects into my
partners and their. But while
the other partner but when the
children are present at these
these events and we all know
that this is very common-
somehow they're left out of the
conversation. And my fear is
that if we don't start
acknowledging in addressing the
issue of children in these
domestic violence situations we
are. Are not assisting in their
mental health- well being and
some of these our kits
unfortunately grow up to. To be
abusers themselves or be
victims because they saw that
it was normal played home and
so one of the things I want to
stress. And continue to stress
and hopefully we can do some
legislative work on it is that
kids are all part of this
conversation as well. And again
yes the resources are for the
victims and- and some cases for
or- the abusers but the kids
need our support as well-
watching their parents- fight
or their mom or dad being
victimized does not do the many
well. Plus I was a former
teacher and- it was unfortunate
that in the classroom you see
manifestations of this abuse I
enough short quick story I was
and. I Ste I taught fourth
grade my last- eight years- I
was a teacher for sixteen years
and no one of my students came
in and he's you know kind of.
Not focusing on my care you
okay as a like no because my
dad was hitting my mom last
night very matter of fact I go
yeah you know my- so we weren't
able to sleep bye. Bye yeah but
I'll be fine. Very matter of
fact and it just hurt me
because for him it was just a
normal occurrence. Right and I
was just like as a teacher I
don't know what to do. Do I say
sorry you do I you know so of
course I went to the
administration. But the point
is that what happens in the
household gets manifested in
the classrooms and sometimes we
wonder why kids are not
achieving. You know we expect
them to go in and be ready to
learn when. There eight have
witnessed domestic violence
either the night before or that
morning sometimes they don't
have food because a lot of the
domestic violence. Are symptoms
are also withholding- monetary-
or money or food or whatever it
may be and the kids are victims
of this as well no I went off
on a little tangent on that one
but I think it's very important
for us to also. I acknowledge
that that work also needs to be
done I'm not just in assisting
the kids but also in counting
him. As part of this is growing
up in the making as much work
as we've done in the last.
Decade I it just feels like we
haven't even. Touched any you
know I just feels that way that
we haven't really done much
work I know we keep. Talking
about it- and again part of the
other reason that I see a
problem is we always try to
address and assist the victims
which is. Great right because
we want to help them right I
don't feel that we're
addressing the actual issue
which is the abuser if the
abuser has mental health issues
other it they have Tehama. And
we're not addressing that issue
we're helping the victims which
again is why what we want to do
but we're not curing were not
really helping the abuser not
abuse anymore so what's going
to happen is. We're going to
remove that family from that
particular abuser but he's
going to go and read that might
here she are it's going to go
be victimized. Another person
because we haven't addressed
their their issues or their
trauma and so it's a
complicated very very
complicated issue and- you know
my hopes is that in the next.
I'm nine years- if I continue
to be. Somebody that I will try
to address that issue in
particular because we can- help
victims unless we are helping-
the abuser well. So anyway the-
the panelists- thank you for
being here but also the
resources we have resources
outside and sometimes we don't
realize that you know it all
and sometimes it just takes a
phone call. We do have a twenty
four seven national domestic
violence hotline can be reached
at. 1-800-799-7233 and- that
should also be part of the
conversation- and- let's see
what else. So we'll go ahead
and get started with our first
panel joining us on the first
panel at law enforcement on
best practices for domestic
violence calls we can be
Espinoza- think he said- she is
from the city of bottom park
and we've- I do. A lot of
together. As Senate and reveals
up as. We have. Aye she's a
community resource officer of
domestic violence advocate for
by the park police department.
Are we have David Rodriguez
patrol sergeant for the Cabana
police department. Janica more
in Pascua community services
officer green police department
and domestic violence
prevention expert. And we're
going to have my towel
detective crimes against
persons unit from the glory
Glendora police department but
popped out before we get
started. I would also like to
acknowledge and thank- those-
of folks that are here in the
audience with us today- first I
would like to think the company
aye ayes city council- is Patty
Cortes a Mister what Walt
Allen- for being here thank you
for opening up your home to us
and- we hope to do more work
with you- in the future. We
also have convene a police
chief John Curley- we have this
is a school board member got an
idea this is here- thank about
Valley- we have a second a
valley LGBT Q. center. Board
member Sarah as a metal we have
a- sees city manager Brian
psyche ward Brian thank you
Brian and this is city manager
manager in your career is here
as well- let's see. And of
course representing senator
Susan reveals off as quite
happen to know a little bit-
is- center Lopez thank you
Sandra I know that the senator
also had. A domestic violence
round table not so long ago so
as you can tell both the
senator and I are committed to
making sure that the resources
folks need. Are available but
also make sure that we. As to
domestic violence I'm and I
believe that's it unless I miss
somebody. I thank you again for
being here let's see. And I'm
some of you know kind of my
background I was a teacher for
sixteen years- prior to being
an assembly member I was a lot
of board member and then a
school board member at the same
time as I was teaching so I
have a lot of experience in
hearing the reports obviously
and seen some of these children
go through that. But I also had
the experience of having my
sister be a victim of domestic
violence and so when I started
in the assembly three years ago
I made it my mission in the
assembly sites to make sure
that- we brought awareness to
that issue I've also passed-
several bills. That act- in my
mind have helped under the one
bill that well there's all the
bills I'm proud of but one of
them in particular- if a victim
of domestic violence is fleeing
from- from the situation and
are under cal works these to
get a voucher for candidates
cycle. I'm so that they can go
and tell them fully- their
abuser well if you're under-
trauma you know that ten days
is you know you're barely does
getting your your parents
together and trying to reach
her from whatever the truck but
you've been suffering soul- the
bill that I passed I extended
that to thirty days. Now they
have- vouchers for thirty days.
You know obviously it's not
enough by the police it's more
than the ten days that- were
previous the are given to the
victims I also had a and my
police- mice public safety
friends can can help me with
this- there is a bill in
particular that was very
difficult I thought from. From
my perspective as though it was
a no brainer. So the federal
government have a life ban on-
a gun if you. Have a-
misdemeanor. Domestic violence
missed. On on owning a gun if
you've had a misdemeanor-
domestic violence and you know
I went in there with you know
all my statistics in LA county.
I'm the to six are eighty nine
percent. 89% of the domestic-
the misdemeanor domestic
violence- with David. Webb and-
re offend and I become felonies
I was eating 9% something king
I got it I got this I've got
all the statistics and I was
met with. Resistance and- the
second amendment was in even
the issue. Which was surprising
to me because I was going to be
faced with you know. In the
second amendment you know and
that was not the issue the
issue what. Are the question
from those public safety
committee to me was the what if
these folks are rehabilitated.
What a have a- person that has
a domestic violence-
misdemeanor is rehabilitated
and I if you know me I'm tend
to be a little bit forward and-
straight forward a little bit
sarcastic sometimes I said the
shin one of the- why do you
need a gun if you're real
validated why do you need a
gun. And so we went back and
forth and- the bill barely
passed I- surprisingly got a
past- I needed for votes and I
had to Republicans and two
Democrats that actually voted-
to pass that bill and I'm happy
to say that it did make it all
the way to the governor's
office and he signed it this
was last year. And it is- the
live California now now it is.
Our with the federal government
that there is a lifetime ban
on. Owning a weapon. Is me. If
you have a misdemeanor domestic
violence. But the reason that I
share. With you. Is because we
all think of these issues are
no brainer is right we all want
to protect. Families well want
to protect victims but when it
comes to the legislative
process- we have so many
different issues. That that
come into play that the things
that I thought were the
bringers are not. So when we
do- bills I to support domestic
violence. Victims I am asking
for your help. I know that I'm
not an expert and I have the
experts here. Why I'm going to
be calling on you for some help
I learned my lesson the last
time I went in. Thinking yeah I
got this is no big deal and it
is. Really a hard fought
battle. And when we go into
battle I would like you to be
part of my- my troops. And so
when we start the legislative
year. I rolled out of the
undoubtedly. Introduced bills
to support victims of domestic
violence and I'll be calling on
all you to help me through that
process so. Anyway thank you-
again for being here and if we
can go ahead and- and get
started- with our panel. Again
the panel on the title of the
panel is law enforcement on
best practices for domestic
violence calls- if you wanna go
ahead and get started since get
the one start. Thank you. Good
morning and thank you this is
an honor to be here so thank
you for having us here my name
said the estamos Lanham with
the bomb park police department
I'm their domestic violence
advocate there I've been there
for ten years and- I do there
like I said domestic violence
and I'm also their
communication sauce officer so
I have a lot of contact with
the community and what the
officers. I'm gonna go ahead
and pass it off. Thank you. My
name's detective Mike howl and
with the Glendora police
department. And not investigate
all the crimes against persons
which include- violence- out
investigations from the scene
all the three prosecution. Hi
my name is Jenna camara Pascua
I work with the Covina police
department and the community
service officer- and I've also
been the domestic violence
field for over twenty years.
Thanks. Good morning- David
Rodriguez police sergeant
Covina PD- they were department
fifteen years- also worked-
domestic violence crimes
against persons- investigations
that it's active select tech
the power here Eklund PD- and
I'll get started as far as the
law enforcement response just
because. I'll give the patrol
aspect of it and then I could.
See as we get to after an
arrest I can hand over to
detective how who's currently
doing investigations. These
these crimes so for Covina more
talk of being in a specifically
to that's what I'm most
familiar with- in two thousand
nineteen we've had over two
hundred M. S. violence calls
for service. And those are the
calls that we get that's not
including unreported domestic
violence incidents it's not
including rapes not including.
Kidnappings stockings is just
purely domestic violence
incidents- so we had over two
hundred. For twenty nineteen.
One resulting in a murder
suicide at an apartment
complex. And it's at the age of
twenty eighteen we also had a
an officer involved shooting.
Resulting from a domestic
disturbance at one of our local
parks. So. The much the call
starts when dispatch gets the
call there's a lot going on
people are highly emotional
these types of- incidents. And
dispatch what their job is
they're trying to identify from
a person who is in distress
whose emotional who screaming
he was yelling who's going
through a lot of stuff- in the
background there's children
screaming and our dispatchers
trying to figure out what
exactly is going on so they
could send units to that to
that residence- they're asking
questions such as is there any
weapons there is anybody hurt-
who's in the house. Is their
children there but what's the
address what's happening they
need to send medical attention
they need captions up
offenders. Or anyone involved.
Already is anybody on the
influence of drugs or alcohol.
Is there any prior history at
that address- has we have we've
been out there before for
similar incidents. Is a
restraining orders on file for
that person- does the person on
the phone eight are they able
to get to a safe place or leave
the house. You know hope it.
Within their hopefully with the
children. And so they're
running the address for the
prior history- and are staying
on the line until the officers
get to the to the residents.
This is the most dangerous type
of call that law enforcement
officers respond to. There's
just winner emotions are
running high with persons
especially persons that are in
relationships- things could get
violent quick. And there's been
times when officers have been
baited by people cooperating
very much and then there ends
up being a physical education-
so they're just they're very-
random and every incident is
different there's no similar
incident when it comes to
domestic violence. So I'll talk
about the officers response now
we obviously a we send a
minimum of two units to these
domestic violence calls that's
a minimum. We need more we
could always ask for more if
they're available. Officers in
a park away from location so
there's not a suspect whiting-
waiting in line and- lying in
wait- hiding and then you know
to assault us- if no one
answers the door officers can
hear what they think is. A
struggle going on inside then
we have a we could use
existence circumstances to
basically force our entry into
their. Parties and the children
they're gonna be separated.
He's going to check for weapons
you know we don't know who's we
don't know who we get is a
suspect or the victim these
types of incidents. At source
separating them we're getting
away from any type of kitchen
where there's you know
potential weapons such as
knives in the bedrooms or there
could be guns- even even check
in the furniture sometimes a
living room just pictures not a
gun hidden in the sofa because
we want to be heard ourselves.
US statements are gonna be came
from both parties so they're
gonna be separated but still
our offices can see each other
in case something happens-
we're gonna try to establish to
the primary aggressors. And
identify that based on
statements from both both
parties as well as any children
witnesses or any independent
party's neighbors or people
that might have heard it. Or
you know just any other
witnesses that were there at
the time so when we gather all
the information. We're gonna
try we're gonna do our best a
terminal primary aggressor in
this. The primary aggressor
doesn't necessarily have to be
someone who you know who struck
someone first it could be you
know maybe of someone poked the
other person and then the other
person gets in the head with a
pot right the prime address is
gonna be the person who use the
pot to solve that person. This
depends on injury. Not on it
the statements are conflicting
which happens a lot of people
are going to you know say
what's beneficial to them so
that they don't get in trouble
if statements are conflicting-
officers they do their best to
is to establish based on it the
totality of all the
circumstances what evidence is
there well as more injuries you
know what the children say-
who's credible and when I say
credible and meeting who's you
know who's intoxicated and
who's not- who was there with
with them still it's all that
stuff gets taken into a- into
account to establish a primary
aggressor to make an arrest.
Disturbance when they're just
when their physical and more
than just a verbal- someone's
going to jail. For the penal
code- so we try to make that
determination the best we can
and arrest someone from that
residents if it's just a verbal
altercation we do our best to
separate the parties have
someone go with a family member
somewhere else. For the
evening- maybe a local motel if
they don't have any family in
the area but we do our best to
we can't force them to leave.
But we do our best to try to
get them to use. To have some
time to cool off. So in
California. What we have family
domestic finds a misdemeanor
domestic violence. The only
domestic violence. Is based on
injury if there is any type of
injury to the person so could
be a scratching him a scratcher
Bruce to. You know. Lacerations
anything that. You know is
consistent with any type of-
any trauma to the body. We
applies to people every day
relationship whether it's
current or prior. If they're
living together. Any children
common if they're married the
are separated or divorced. The
misdemeanor domestic violence
is an allegation of being.
Being struck or any type of
physical- altercation occurred
of happen. So maybe if someone
says yeah he punched me in and
I have a to show for it we're
still gonna rest. You know
whoever the offender was that
punch the other person. We also
have a two seven three six was
of violating a domestic
violence restraining orders of
something already happen. And
that and offender comes back
and violates restraining order.
Then they get arrested for that
as well. Officers are gonna
document everything in a police
report they're gonna
photographed the scene they're
gonna photograph both parties.
Just so that says that the
statements are consistent as
well. And they're going to
consider. Number C. protective
order which is a restraining
order that can be done right
then and there calling a judge
doesn't matter any time of the
night the judge gets called and
we tell the judge exactly what
happened verbally and days
either grant restraint or they
don't rather straining or based
on the totality of everything.
And then hopefully that person
is there so we can provide them
with their copy the restraining
order so that they know they
can't come back for believe
it's- thirty days. And days
three days. Seven seven days
ago. And then a that that put
that give the- victim sometime
to get rid their own
restraining order from the
courthouse. Zero so at these
were also doing department of
children's services- referrals
at these locations if there's
children there they have
children of their children
there. There's offices can
automatically do a referral to
DCFS. And at the edge Chen a
east cars will be generated and
they'll be some follow up to be
conducted by agents from that
department. So at that time. A
detective will be assigned a
case and the to they'll take it
the district attorney's office
for consideration of a filing
for misdemeanor felony- and
then the judicial system
basically takes over determines
jail prison- anger management
classes restraining orders. And
that's based work I'll give
that to the park to the
detective how lawyer from going
to a party but that's our
police patrol officer response
to these domestic violence
incidents which are very
extremely dangerous. One just
to point out- you know this
whole entire time the emotions
are are high not just on there
and by. The officers that are
responding to those calls also
have to be careful about what
happened you saw what happened
Sacramento to that that young
officer that responded to a
domestic violence- call and so.
That should not be overshadowed
either because that domestic
violence is happening within
that household but we have
other victims are other
potential victims in in our law
enforcement that's trying to
you know- deal with that
situation so I just. Want to
say that in thank you I know
it's a tough job and you know
we want to make sure that we do
everything possible to support
law enforcement because at the
end of the day your support and
you also. Supports those
victims. Thank we appreciate
that thank you. What will said
the project that. So. In my
opinion the most balanced cases
are actually very difficult to
investigate. First of all a lot
of times you have witnessed
there your time to on a he said
she said type of incidents.
Where you don't know it's hard
to tell who the primary
aggressor in it's hard for the
district attorney when either.
That the right tell who it is.
In without that witness or a
statement from the suspect
thing yeah I did this I did
that. It's hard them to
prosecute a lot of cases get
the client. And as the wait
wait is. Are we do have
witnessed available like a
child which is unfortunate but
a off my child will be there a
child will say what happened. A
lot times this district
attorney feels more comfortable
we have a witness like that
that says this is actually what
happened. In a separate things
out. In being an investigator.
What I wanna say this that. You
have to have some understanding
and compassion these cases it's
going to understanding what the
female or male has been going
through your dinner stand that
they may have been married
twenty years five years what
are maybe. They may have
children- this is not an easy
thing for them to go through to
separate all and they want to
stay together and you. Will do
the best a cation you last the
victim male female. What do you
want to now. Do want that
person prosecuted for doing
this the time. You're talking
about a week later is the
answer is no they don't. You
have to understand why though
in the reason being is because
they're a is highly emotional.
Feelings they have. Share bank
accounts share mortgage. On
their lan each other for to get
by so. Something happens in
often when a victim does not
want prosecution anymore the
district will not prosecute
that case unless we have a good
evidence or a victim that can
see otherwise for us. Thank you.
I'm just some statistics on
average it takes a person seven
times before they actually
leave an abusive relationship
so an officer's gonna respond
many times this is the tenth
time they've been to this
house- and the increase of
danger increases when that
person leaves the relationship
so within the first seventy two
hours that a person leases on
that their highest risk of
being killed. So those all have
to be taken into consideration
as well if that person knows
their partner better than
anybody else they know the
danger that they possibly can
be and if they try to leave
this situation- even if at the
moment it might be the best
situation the- danger really
increases for them. Thank you
any okay. I do want to add to
what you just said I'm there on
the for you know for the
officers the one thing that has
helped us having army there I
have the first contact with the
victim so when the Victor comes
in sometimes obviously she
doesn't want to talk to the
officers so- I go ahead and set
up an appointment with them.
There's going to be times when
she doesn't want to come in but
I persist on the call right I
you know tell them what I do I
let them know that I'm not an
officer but at that I'm here to
help so one of the things that
has helped us is that I never
ask why are you still there
because I know that it takes
many years I was actually a
victim of domestic violence it
took me over ten years to
actually get out. So I think
that helps us there with the
police department to have me
there because again I've relate
my re you know the past
relations with the victims so I
pretty much much know exactly
what they're thinking that-
half finance their own have
somewhere to go there are
afraid they're being threatened
with the kids so one of the
things that I always. I ate
here their story and I actually
went but I do. Tell them. Is I
let them know that I was a
victim. And that I did it not
for myself for that I wasn't
thinking about everybody else.
But because I didn't want my I
have two boys. And I don't want
them to actually do the same to
other females. So I kinda go in
that direction where we have to
help. And cut the circle kind
of the cycle went to make sure
that. They understand if they
continue being those
relationships. It's hard but
they're just going to continue
and their children will
continue doing the same thing
and accepting. In their lives.
So that's what we do there.
That's what's easier for us to
go ahead and have that
relationship with the victim.
And then to that- comment or
those the information. I want
to ask in general because I
know that- senator Rubio just-
passed a bill about training-
is there. And I'm don't want to
put you on the spot is there.
Some kind of a training- that
assists- the law enforcement
officers because- you know. It
you're explaining all of this
but it right away I'm thinking.
What experience you know do you
have. And you know are you
treating this call. As you know
just another call and that you
know you did explain that it's
very different. But I guess my
own walk left already. He was
there the trainer of some of
those. At. Will work. Thank you
and then to that question as
well as you know what- do your
cities have in place right now-
in terms of support for the
officers and- training- when
assisting in these calls
because I can't again I just
can't imagine you know your
blood is pumping in your
adrenalin is pumping and having
to answers to some of these
calls not knowing if you're
going to be a victim of the
some something or you're gonna
find already somebody sees I
mean that would be my biggest
fear is that when I write that
you there's already people that
have been. You know injured.
Yeah we're very lucky to have
Chen occurred our department
because she's a good liaison to
have with the with her
experience and where she works-
you know rather to jobs that
she has. So but we there is
specialized training that you
know officers could get sent to
as as- Mister Allen said
earlier you know the academy
there increasing your their
hours there's a block is a
forty hour block a plea for
domestic violence- but it's
great to have a liaison it you
know ballpark of you know it
you know. I'm sure week maybe
we could do something regional.
Where you know them sure not
every please park and have that
but- she's a regional resource.
And you know just providing
briefing trainings and talking
officers that alone is
beneficial she puts on formal
training as well- she expand on
that. Some of the training that
you give up. As I've been able
to do the briefings with
officers provide those
resources. When they'd go out
on calls and there's victims
and we have a direct link.
Where they can call our twenty
four hour helpline as well. And
places victims into- the
emergency shelter. That is the
local shelter in the San
Gabriel Valley area which is
the wings shelter. Thank you
and then so a follow up
question- what barriers. Do you
see our I mean I'm sure there's
a many by the way. What are the
top maybe one or two barriers
that you see- in. Assisting or
serving domestic violence
victims. I know money is part
of it but. If we aye what are
the biggest barriers anything.
I think for us a ballpark I
think it's all the time I we do
I think I S. we both do
different in a way where
different nam hats there in the
city so it's a little bit hard
but I think one of the things
is all the training. For us I
think within often this out
enough but as far as barriers I
mean it's just more of the time
in the funding for the
departments. Thank you and
then. So barriers for the-
victims well and you providing
services for the victims. I
think one of the biggest things
is just like you mentioned
working with the kids and
helping to build that
prevention piece and working
with the entire family so we
really try to provide
education- to the community as
well as- helping to teach
people what a healthy
relationship looks like so that
that cycle stocks because it is
a learned behavior. Thank you
and then- one last question-
because I think- this is our
last- domestic violence hearing
of the ear so this is our
fourth line and what I also
have been- hoping to address is
the LGBTQ community because I
know all- being in Mexican- you
know being of Mexican. Just
facts a whole nother level of
barriers if you well you know
our our communities don't
necessarily accept LGBT Q. no
kids and so I feel like. And as
a school board member I also
saw then specially in middle
school some of those kids- bore
suicidal- and then they got
involved in relationships that
were not healthy and they
continue to get the views
because they didn't feel
comfortable coming out to their
parents or you know whatever-
what have you a whole bunch of.
Of more more issues to the LG
to be a kid community because
you know if women and men are.
Ashamed of speaking out I am
trying to get help for domestic
violence I know the deal to Q.
community also as you know and
is more- prevalent especially
in Latino communities and I am
from ballpark so when I was a
little bit board member
involved in park I thought
that. Was a big issue is there
any you know anything else that
we can do a visual. Train any
partners just what the hell to
up. Community that we think we
can help with raging so that
you all have the resources for
that particular community as
well. I think one of the a good
idea that I think would be good
is actually trying to get into
the school districts like the
actual high school's. Junior
highs because we actually see
this happening at a younger age
I know that for a fact so I
think if we were to partner up
with the school districts and
start there. In you know bring
some of these programs and talk
about it I mean the talk about
everything else might as well
start talking about the- the
teen dating out the violence
behind it- and then you know
adding more of the other stuff
information that students need
to know. Perfect domestic
violence affects everyone so
it's no gender- and really it's
about building an inclusive
community so where everyone
feel safe to reach out for
resources and letting them know
where they're at so with the
officers they're able to
provide resources when they go
out on phone I mean out on
calls that were able to give
out numbers so that whoever it
is in the community that's
being affected has a place
where they can call when
they're ready. Thank you. Any
other comments that you think-
should hear about. Yeah I think
I think it's just report as
Walter mine officers is not
always he said she said anymore
you know it's you could have
been done if anybody's just
remember like eight but he
could be a victim- you know
when we're going to calls and
you see two males are two
females. It's not a battery
it's a domestic violence yet
this that was that
relationship. And that's the
and I'm time I like the dating
relationship yes absolutely
ship as well as- a builder for.
Now someone might you know they
might have some intuitions
about officers and we might you
know not. Be sure of what we're
dealing with exactly so- again
training- and just and you
asked earlier about some of the.
The is like the- the problems
are the trump some of the
troubles was earlier question.
What the barriers there- and a
lot and a lot of it is
cooperation victim cooperation
it's hard to get a to get to
get a victim to cooperate
because you might you know a
month later they may be back
with that person and they don't
want anything done and then it
kind of puts you know the law
enforcement and the judicial
system out of. At a standstill
so to say. Wiseman and- that's
our whole other topic but you
know the- social media-
bullying and- stocking and I.
Really is. I'm also domestic
violence even though it's been
there's no physical interaction
and I just social media brings
a whole nother level of. Of I
wish I love it but I hate it at
the same time because I see a
lot you know even within my
own- friends and I'm- barred
from the leading people because
I'm a state of officials I
can't delete folks but I see
some of the things they post
and it's- it just makes me
cringe. Because where you are
modeling for kids really you
know some of these folks that
that start posting no
inappropriate content an
appropriate on pictures you
know they think it's no big
deal by they don't. You don't
realize that their kids are
watching our kids are watching
and you know it also adds
another layer of a of abuse and
sell but that'll be for another
conversation because I think we
can pull up a whole other on.
Day on bills to sit that
specific issues so I just want
to thank you for providing your
your comments and not thank you
for the work that you do and
again I want to be a partner
with you and I know that-
senator Susan would be as
office. No were. Were excuse me
for both. To ensure that we
make some kind of headway- with
domestic violence I think. You
know I wish I can say that we
can- completely. I'll get rid
of it but the unfortunate- part
is that we know that we can
sell- anyway would thank you
very much- and you know.
Hopefully you'll be around for
questions. The other thing that
I found in my previous-
meetings that some folks that
that may be here. That have
questions or not. I'm going to
ask in public so please be if
you can make yourself available
for anybody. We need to be
sources or just somebody to
talk to I really would
appreciate. Thank you very much.
Kill him then so next. Our next
panel. Is our local rest are
resources available to
survivors and their families
and we have today we have
severe Rodriguez. Senior
manager of family services YWCA
of Central Valley. We also have
Angela- air community advocate
center for the- Pacific Asian
family- doctor Rebekah guys-
director of programming and
lead psychologist back- Becky's
angels international. If you
can join us on the panel I'd-
appreciate it and just. To give
you a little bit of background
the last three- hearings have
dealt with. Issues such as-
culturally appropriate hello
because a lot of folks I
depending on their culture
believe that you know you keep
your dirty laundry. On behind
closed doors- some folks are
taught at an early age that you
do not reveal you do not talk
about you just think it because
that's your duty and so
hopefully we can address some
of those- issues- if you ladies
today so thank you for being
here a few control. Yourself.
Family. And I to quiet the-
yeah so Angela air I'm one of
the community advocates at
center for the pensions of the
Civic Asian farming skews me.
Hi my name is Sophia Rodriguez
on the senior manager of family
services at the YWCA of sank
able values domestic violence
program I'm also marriage and
family therapist there. Thank
you and if you would like to
start you know if you have any
comments are or we can you know
ask I can ask him questions
that I did a lot of police
officers- whatever you're more
comfortable with because I know
that- your you've done a lot of
work in this field and so if
you maybe start by sharing a
little bit about what your
background is and what- how use
of- domestic violence. Victims.
At the White easier thank April
Valley we have to programs in
our domestic violence. Inside
we have our residential program
which includes domestic
violence shelter- within our
domestic violence shelter we
have emergency and transitional
housing. And in our non
residential we are sixteen
weeks support group as well as
our community education program.
In the last year we've served
over one thousand individuals
who are experiencing domestic
violence and this includes
children. And then- similar to
what wings does in our program
we specifically focus on the
Asian Pacific Islander AB and
community in regards to
domestic violence and sexual
assault services- we have the
only emergency shelter in
southern California that
specifically focuses on this
population including language
capacity. And then we- offer to
of read transitional shelter
programs on that Sir about
population and- to address some
of the questions that you had
brought up earlier one of the
issues that we find is that
there is a huge lack of
language services- and because
of that- because a lot of our
clients that we serve for
immigrants as well- they're-
able or unwilling to access. On
the services. That we provide
for working on trying to. So I
have a little bit of a
different agenda- almost city
sorry from my age. I'm I had
one two and three that I wanted
to cover would that be okay
absolutely okay so first of all
it's an honor to meet you thank
you for the invitation. This
last minute I'm so grateful to
be here. The first thing I
wanted to talk about was a
little bit about my story and
why I'm here- I actually was-
well I am an immigrant from
Mexico I came here at age nine.
And. Had suffered a lot of
experience a lot of domestic
violence my own parents- we
were in Chicago. And my mother
my father in this you know I.
Say about the male victim truly
believe in the male victim my
father was the male victim. I
only got four years of.
Interaction my father but it
takes one parent. To raise a
stable person a stable child
and I hope that I'm semi stable.
In a reflection of those four
years that I had but so my
mother kidnapped us and brought
us here to California- I don't
want to get too deep into the
story but just a little bit
about why I'm here because I
think it has substance- I came
here at age. Twelve to
California- with my mother and
eighty four month old brother-
my mother had a lot of issues
TV multi provisional pattern
for us well- in left me- here
as a child so I became a mom at
twelve years old of a four
month old baby and I struggled
I live the streets. Up is being
from DCFS I and I say I have
substance because I want to get
into when I get into the
resources and my request for
resources- so I actually
survived- out in the street
basically I work seven days a
week I went to school I hid
from the system. I had you know
my cheese also neighbors that
helped me- Reyes brother
sometimes they are you know
they're a great resource to you
are in so with that at age
fourteen ended up with- in high
school with my abuser so. I
ended up and he I was in the V.
for twenty six years with my
abuser and I can tell you the
in and out of Y. victim stay
and I fell up some framework
around that that work- I recall
being a child in sitting in a
corner. Of covering my ears and
telling myself that I was never
going to be anything. In life
and I had no hope for life.
Then I re experience that in my
own TV. I remember- living with
my abuser is sitting in a
bathroom corner by the toilet
saying just. I want in my life
you know but I guess I didn't
have enough courage to do that.
Or I had my brother to take
care of. So having said that
the second thing that I want to
talk about is how- it make his
angels got established- I
actually went to school- during
my TV. And I was hiding to go
to school supposedly I was
working in but I was actually
going to school behind the
scenes so that my abuser would
not find out. I lived a lot of
terror in that relationship.
But is strengthened me and
that's reason why I'm here- I
ended up leaving my abuser
after twenty six years. And I
give all the credit. To officer
Gus was sitting in the back.
Always here supporting me all
over there he moved. He
actually after I left my abuser
I met him. And he is the person
that Tami whether true love
less about and what a healthy
relationship less about he the
person that protected for my
abuser. And we ended up getting
married for a year but in all
the hopping from one
relationship to the other which
a lot of TV victims do doesn't
work out but we love each other
like. Family. He's always there
to support me and- you know he
he will be he will be what made
me who I am today. Because of
that I decided I want to go
back to school so I went and
got my a Sadie in France a
clinical psychology because I
wanted to work with the victims.
So in my internship I wanted to
understand the perpetrator. And
what I did is I actually did my
first internship là AB one day
where the twin palms. I
discovered a lot I discovered
that they are also victims and
I really appreciate what you
said earlier about not
addressing the aggressor they
are victims but I feel that
there is chemical issues
involved with the aggression
peace. And that is why the
aggressor is the aggressor I'm
in so Becky saying gills came
about on my second internship I
decided that- to put together
based on my own reflection
framework. The framework is
that if I knew my legal rights.
I would have gotten out wait
earlier. I the second thing
would be therapy how do I deal
with my past traumas and stay
grounded in stable in the third
piece is formal education
because I it I am a former I am
a an educator I am actually a
college professor full and so
everything that I do is donated
time- with back his angels. And
I felt that having that
education is what really save
my life and that of my children
because I see that they are
breaking the cycle of violence.
So in terms of support- I am
here to say that one of the
biggest disappointments working
out in the community is a lot
of competitiveness among agency
rather than- being United and
not talking about this area I'm
talking about I do a lot of
work in LA. And so my mission
is to move out here because I
hear that there's a scarce you
know the resource are very
scarce on here it is something
this is where my heart started
in a hope to move out here
secondly everything that I do
with Becky's angels is out of
pocket and is extremely
difficult and stressful and I
have to tell you just two weeks
ago I wanted to close down the
clinic because I am tired. I
haven't funding I have a child
in college- you know to write
grants I'm the only one that
does all this work on my own.
And so my phone is constantly
blowing up. Third thing is one
of my missions is to get
together with different
agencies to put victims first
and not funding to that's one
of the things that I discover.
Like I said it was a huge
disappointment that's white-
I'm working you know where I'm
working in so to put together a
group of agencies within their
reach and- to get together at
least once a month to discuss.
Best practices for the area
best practices how we can share
sources to help are victims in
our community. Lastly I get
disappointed every October
because this is the second
awareness meeting that I at
ten- related to domestic
violence. We're not out in the
spotlight in October and I know
that cancer month it that's
also important but if you look
at stats. D. V. dads are higher.
Dodd then people die from
cancer breast cancer. And so
what does that tell you we need
more awareness in our community
we need more support and it
takes you guys to bring that
the know that support- there
was something else I wanted to
share. Add Becky singles how
that god created us in my
second internship- I did I put
my for work I develop
curriculum around it a lot of
what the officer set is
collaboration with the PD I can
connect with everything each
person said at this table in
the first panel. Because that's
what it takes it takes
collaborative work between PD
and are agencies as well as the
community- one of the things
that I discover is- the officer
talked about the CFS. I deal
with most of the DCFS cases
where the children are removed
because the victim was in TV
that's such a punitive system
the children go to date go to
foster care because I work with
them all the way into
reunification. And they come
back for someone they left
there's something wrong with
the system and I went through
that myself so I know first
hand- the second thing that has
been extremely helpful and I've
been managing to kind of keep a
float in LA. Is a one stop
center what does that mean when
the victim- and the children
get removed the victim goes to
court is having an advocate
like the lady that was here and
this and- to talk to the victim
to will testify to hop in bed
processes because the dark very
dark tunnels call it a- whole
this lonely. For I and you have
no one by your side if I would
have somebody like her I would
done wonders. But I did and I
had to do everything by myself
was all he was a support. The
one steps their children- cord
will may take the individual.
To prevent losing their job
they go there and they get all
the resources in one day. They
learn they collaborate with
other people they become
friends and they help each
other as a community so I am
hoping that. You support me
what that are support us and
I'm hoping to mean more than
seize in this area and that I'm
welcome in this area because I.
Everything I do is doesn't I'm
not looking for money I'm
looking for work and I'm
looking for results. Thank you.
Thank you thank you for your
story- you know and- it's true
that you know we all walk- and
talk to people and have no idea
what they've gone through or
what they're going through
right now. Once I really
appreciate you opening up- or
story- but it up and it also
makes as reflect again on the-
services that are not provided
and one of the issues that I
mentioned earlier. You know how
point is language. Appropriate
resources because. In this area
for example you know we have- a
Spanish is the primary language
but I commute back and forth
from San Diego on a we have a
big. Ending community care and
so that that- we are the need
for a different language there
is very different than it is
in. The center valley and soul
can you maybe speak on on what
you are all doing to provide
those language services and-
are you even able to meet the
demand- for those language-
services. Sure so- firstly
thank you for pointing that out
one of the biggest issues and
that we do find is that- cam
with language. If I am an
immigrant individual of English
is not my primary language. I'm
afraid to speak out because I
don't know what my resources
are I don't know if I go to
DCFS office if. By exposing
myself- and giving information
about my abusive partner
whoever they may be. If I may
be detained or deported that
kind of thing. And a lot of-
API. Survivors of domestic
violence and sexual stole.
Personally because of the
cultural stick marketing our
dirty laundry but again because
of that fear that they're going
to get out it they don't know
the resources are there. So
what seat half the agent's cam
phone was trying to accomplish
is- providing that kind of
intermediary a service where we
can help them navigate the
systems that we have here in
California in language- this
includes things like going to
DC fast going to court-
children supervision
accompaniments- we also do-
start a company. So sexual.
Assault response team like when
he. I individuals at the
Medical Center getting the exam
done we are there to offer
emotional support and kind of
guide them through that
process- one of our issues is
that we are primarily based on
create town that's where a
community center is. But as I
think everyone here probably is
aware of so many Asian folks
are out here in the same people
Valley. And in fact a lot of
our- survivors that come to us
through a hotline or calling
from here. And the problem with
that is that some of them maybe
to drive- some are fearful to
do so. Traffic is awful- so
what we're trying to do is as
you were mentioning as well-
partner more with- individuals
and agencies in this area to.
Choose firework farther east
work because that's definitely
where the need is- we have done
quite a bit of- recently
preventative work with API
youth. In think Iran all hambre
on in this is to hold break a
whole culture of violence
thing- so things like TV in the
home- teen dating violence.
What we're wanting to spread
our case management and
counseling mental health TV
services for on this area. So
we're hoping that. You know
interested parties will come
reach out connect. Question so
when you're talking about- you
know collaboration do you guys-
have you know kind of a system
where you see a you know I can
call. And see if she they can
help me with this language that
we don't I mean if there. Is it
just you guys are doing in a
reserve some kind of a central
I mean I have no idea so that's
why I'm asking because it just
seems like. You know if you can
provide some of those- last
systems in that language that
you know some of the other
agencies can benefit from your
resources. To be able to help
folks navigate in their own
language so- one of the great
things about our program not
not to like puff it up or
anything is that you should you
should. Absolutely that's why
we're here. I think you it's we
have a twenty four hour
hotline. And we have a team of
about forty folks right now
we're very small- but the most
of a speak a secondary.
Language so when someone calls
if the council. On the hotline
does speak that language we can
connect with a staff member
that does. If that's offer may
not be available we also have a
look like a huge volunteers
speak various languages and me.
Connect to different services
that can provide an interpreter
over the phone. And so I think
they mean that I mean it makes
it. More accessible even if
it's just to inform the
survivor of research- and I
think role it is you know when
you call us. You don't have to
leave right now. Sometimes it's
impossible. And we have the
safety number. Makes so much
more welcoming and- how little
to even discuss TV in the first
place. You know I am sure that
the majority of the
constituency that I represent
its primary Spanish or Hispanic
and- do you have any of the
issues that that the Latino
immigrant community has I have
experience with some folks
that. Know the mother wouldn't
leave because the father was
like you know if you leave I'm
gonna report to all to
immigration and in I'm gonna
get you departed and so that
constant fear. Also as a you
know obviously a barrier by but
I don't want to assume because
I think you know what we talk
about with all of the right we
all this team that that the
immigration issues is papered
on aids is mainly for the I
Latino Hispanic community. But
I would like if you share the
issues that you will run into
in terms of- immigration and
you know being threatened- for
their immigration status as
well because again we all seem
to think that it's just a lot
in the community that's going
to this but I want. You know-
acknowledge that it's not just
that but the community so if
you can address or not sure of
your experience in that area
sure I mean definitely. In in
the entry media it it there's a
huge focus on the Latino
community in the immigration
issue. But definitely I think
just historically throughout
the years with the A. K.
community- so many of us coming
in. But sometimes it happens
sure I and whatever- but when
they get to the states- if
they're within the beast a
partner who is a citizen or-
someone who has some form of
status. Or or not even- they're
constantly getting the threat
of. If you do X. Y. Z. I'm
gonna call the police and
they're going to arrest you in
the many arrested again get
deported- you have no access to
services out here because you
don't have status. It's a very
very common feared I think a
lot of our clients have. So
actually most of my survivors a
common in house to our shelter
programs. In fact. Almost all
of them have immigration issues
that we have to sort through.
Whether that's getting- their
own visa going through the
green card process accessing-
status through Volos of
violence against women act.
Because they have to separate
their own immigration case from
their abusive partner. And then
our runner solo- and then we
have quite a few Israelis as
well- they fled their home
country and then they came here
and then. You know more stuff
happened. On so. Choose to
return your question it's very
very prevalent. I can actually.
Thank you thank you for that.
At the White ABC of San Gabriel
Valley we never deny anybody
based on language we've been
very creative in how we're able
to provide all the services
that we offer to any client
regardless of the language-
anything from bringing in
interpreters we- also use the
language line. That is this
with our crisis twenty four
hour hotline- in addition we
have worked with other
agencies- to be able to provide
our clients the services. I
didn't want to touch on
something that you mentioned
and that was- the need. For
funding for services for
clients oftentimes DCFS does
require. Individual counseling
parenting domestic violence
services and although all of
our services are free we found
it really difficult to connect
our clients with individual
casting and parenting that is
free. And especially if they
are leaving their home and the-
are already trying to figure
out housing. Then it makes it
really difficult to play an out
of pocket for the services so I
did want to touch back on them.
Thank you for that- if I may.
First I want to see thank you
see Pat is wonderful I have
worked with you guys- in LA-
and I don't know for. Me
personally I feel. Competent
enough culturally to be able to
serve- you know like the Asian
Pacific- community so we do do
a lot of work and they're very
responsive so I wanted to
publicly thank him for that
because I had a case. Not too
long ago where I was and I
think it was that LA community-
hospital. And the victim had
just gotten here and same thing
exactly what you said and I
made a call. And then they came
right to the hospital they took
over. Of for me personally what
we do because I can't stretch
out I mean very stressed out
already. Is I let them know
that I rather you know. That
transform over to a place where
they're going to understand
their needs more but I'm not
going to leave them. And I
remember this client holding my
hands couldn't make it with me.
But she believe me you know I
wasn't gonna leave until
someone came. And just the
happened over was like a big
deal for her because she felt
that safety piece. Thank you so
much thank here your
administrators for the nice
work that you guys do in. LA
and I'm really hoping that they
get reported out here. Thank
you all and in terms of funds
you know it's always a battle
and- Sacramento with the budget
and- but I do think that
there's other ways that we can
support- I. Hope we have some
some local grant writers that
work for cities and school
districts all you know I want
to ask them to do. Pro bono the
eat you know how grant writing
arts eventually they get paid.
Based on the grounds that they
receive except for what they do
in cities and in school
districts as they get a monthly
retainer for that. So there's
one in particular that I want
to- kind of talk to see if
they're willing to at least do
that I'm pro bono and then they
can get paid based on the on
the grounds that they received
because I think. You know even-
at the state level last year-
senator bell and I were eight.
Six twenty million dollars for
domestic violence right and
then because it was a big.
Issue well apparently it wasn't
that big of issue this time we
only got forty five. Thousand
dollars think about that forty
five thousand for the whole
state. Forty five thousand for
the whole state and so is sold
the battle begins again. I
thought I'd Hey we got twenty
million you know we were going
to keep getting this funding.
Well lo and behold you know
that was on a per eighty this
year so it was forty five
thousand dollars. So the fight
begins and luckily for me I
have now another- ally in the
Senate- that we can.
Collaborate with to try and get
and the these grants right
through. The department of
emergency services- backed-
organizations such as yours cam
can access by forty five
thousand dollars is not gonna
get you anything- bites- I'm
going to need you again next
year on the fender and I and-
us and Rubio havoc- committed
to. To making that budget ask
again it's a long process. And
it's basically it's like you
know a cracks you know you
throw that if any hope that the
lands on where you want it to
be. But in the meantime I do
want to connect you with some
of these local fund a- grant
writers. And all make the page
and ask them to do. You know
something at and help you with
some of these grant writing-
because I know even writing a
grant is just. You know hours
and hours of work in research.
And so I please commit to that
I'm committing to having a
budget ask a follow up here.
And hopefully we can you know
keep make. Asking your to the
point where they could they-
not. Leave them open and up to
one. Point five. Those who have.
Hold on community- baby in
reality it is and it's a it's a
you know. A California problem-
and- through the work that I
was doing I also found that-
domestic violence if we want to
talk about budget- costs.
Millions and millions of
dollars that if we put invested
in the prevention and the
support. We would be able to
not spend but that's a whole
again. You know that
conversation. Goals kind of.
Out of sight out of mind with
some of these folks because
they they- look at. You know
budgetary- priorities like.
Parks which are important but-
you know. Sometimes we have to
balance that can I add
something now that you mention
parks. One of the biggest-
pieces for me facility. I
started LGBT open their doors-
to. In groups there and I a no
I don't in my time. I have on
an average of thirty to forty
people. Upper group we need
every Saturday. And part of
that work is because I was so
terrified. The police. When
they can feel comfortable they
make the police their friends
you know they start
collaborating- in every cities
region in those types of
resources so for me ideally my
dream would be to have all of
us in one building when we can
just say Hey who can serve this
victim. Thank you thank you
that- that is a great goal and
hopefully we can get to that
point so I want to thank you
again for participating and you
know again you die if you make
yourself available for folks
and you know if they need help
or you know just resources are
connecting get to know each
other at some point you can
collaborate and you know how-
and a couple years can have
this will stay where control in
what like. They did so thank
you for your participation
thank you. Thank you and then
our third panel- we have- we're
going to spotlight on local
LGBT Q. plus. Resources and- de
stigmatizing- domestic
violence- today we have Serra
Acevedo board members and uber
valley LGBT Q. center. Deanna
Herrera victims advocate St
John's transgender health
programs- Sophia Rodriguez
senior managers manager of
family services at. The YWCA of
Sanger bro Bally will continue-
with us on the panel- if you
can take a seat and please
introduce yourself and- let us
know a little bit about your
background- so that we can not
continue with the conversation.
Hi my name is Sarah seven
though I am a board member of
the think able Valley LGBT Q.
center and also the secretary
of the board and the director
of programs there. Hello my
name is Tanner Herrera and I
work for St John's for one of
the biggest transcend help
programs in the nation a
worldwide. And I'm also part of
that- transgender advisory
board counts for the city of
Los Angeles. In the voice of
five million people and I also
work with LAPD LGBT working
group. Hello as I introduced
myself earlier one of the
things I did want to mention is
that all of our services at the
White AB CA are. On inclusive
to all genders. Thank you. Arm
well I just wanted to address
that. St John's onscreen
providing healthcare to the
public for over fifty years-
the started from the basement
of the cathedral and Adams in
flower. Of Serbian the-
minorities who are especially
on document it so from there-
that's where they started and
then within time we expanded to
sixteen clinics. So now our
focus the mission of the Johns
are focused seen on serving
Donna. Some of Los Angeles in
any part of. Of the U. S.
because not only when we
started our transgender health
program. Which was five years
ago we started with eight
patients a transgender patients
within the period of. Five
years we have expanded to
serving two thousand five
hundred trans gender. And
through our transgender health
program not only do we offer a
hormone replacement therapy we
offer meant mental health. And
we also focus on the public
because the chances of AB
papers clinic and we also serve
the undocumented population say
they don't have any health
insurance or or anything at
all- they would not be
discriminated or turn down
based on color race religion or
gender- everybody will be seen.
And if you have private
insurance or if you have medi
cal or Medicare that's a plus
because to our transgender help
program. Our patients one of
the being patient of ours for
about a year not only do they
qualify for gender dysphoria
surgeries- that the medi cal or
the private insurance. Will
cover and that's reason why
would he have our therapist in
our clinicians because he comes
out of our clinic so. Our
clinicians they need to know
there are patients are mentally
stable in order to we see
whatever perjury that they're
seeking because there's certain
surgeries that they just cannot
be reverts. So through that
once they're done with their
therapy they submit the
referrals and they're ready to
go and not only do we have. Our
wonderful staff but we also
have our victims advocate
program specifically for our
trans individuals we have been
victims of hate crime for
suspects were human trafficking
and torture and domestic
violence. Me my thought hasn't
avocat- the working for seen.
John place are working there
thousand Eckstine September
eleven. What's the big myself.
Of hate crimes and once not
twice but three times so based
on that of putting myself out
there. Of survive means- doing
to sex work even though I do
have a high school diploma have
higher college education. It
was very difficult for me to
get a job or to be employed for
the simple fact of just being
who I am being a trans woman of
color. So things to think
John's opened up a lot of doors
a lot of players for myself. To
advocate not only for my
community but also advocating
for the public and for the
undocumented- as an immigrant.
I focus on the public because
it wouldn't be right for me
just. The focus on the LGBT
community N. are victims
advocate program. One of my
coworkers which is no the
cruise. He's our new with
avocat that he's Charlene and
he's willing to learn as much
as- not only for all but the
rest of the team. En us we
connect them with whatever it
is that they're speaking- not
only to mental health health
care. And whatever it is that
the need to go. To the right
date. Of what they're looking
for and throughout. Our program
we also have our Neiman Marcus
James which we help our transit
individuals. I'm to make their
lives but- changed their name
and mark on. Their driver's
license in California ease in
all. Our transit parliament
program which helps our
patients. Excuse me on how to
create the resume needs are job
interviews and how to behave ed
themselves in a professional
work environment and what they
completed all. Of the big. An
opportunity where they would
not be given the who they are.
And on top of that we also have
our dental which is open and
available for everyone so if
example if we have an
undocumented patient the house
no kind of on employment
history or whatever it is that
they're doing to make the ends
meet they call based. On their
income so is there on a human
it is likely they will qualify
for my health LA which is-
it'll cover health care mental
in dental. And medication and
if it's a surgery that it's
medically necessary. It can
also be covered as long as as
their provider- does the refer
all. And based on that- I've
learned to grow so much through
the thing John not only that
they empowered me but- I was
one of their first patients and
employee who has gone. The
majority of- gender dysphoria
surgeries. Approved in other
words I have opened up a lot of
doors for our transit leans who
are seeking- third and
surgeries. And through my
advocacy- able to advocate more
through the transgender
advisory board counsel for the
city of Los Angeles being a
voice for five million people
and also in collaboration with
the LAPD IGBT working group.
Because my passion to me is
advocating for my community and
through my higher education. I
just wanted a simple degree
which with my associates in
corrections well corrections
the transfer. But I was able to
check for. You make jokes of
course is in with able to get.
My that's my associates my
pastors and could not just is
not working on my masters in
behavior science. Thank you so
much- for the act and to that-
you one of have I do you have
any comments or anything that
you would like us to. Know and
then I'll ask a couple
questions as well say- so just
some quick history on the
center valley LGBTQ center
we've been around since twenty
eleven- started Pasadena as the
Pasadena pride center. And we
started simply with your
support groups and during those
work groups we discovered that
there were many many
underlining issues that each of
us face- as LGBT Q. people kind
of set up more interceptions
than most people. So we get a
lot of people of different
races different ethnicities
different classes- we didn't
get some survivors a DP- IPV on
is a part of our current
events- we don't get a lot of
them because we don't have. A
fake are programs that service
those people because we are
entirely volunteer based CA.
Everyone that works all of our
board members nobody is paid
we're all their optical and
here basis- so a lot of the
work we do is. In addition to
our regular jobs- and don't
have a permit. Space right now
we partner with the. Arcadia
you see see. Around seventy
demos Tunis and they have a
they own historical mansion and
so we operate out of that
during our- hours are the only
times. That we are open we
don't have walking hours but we
do have- Google voice number
which is our phone. And anyone
can call anytime and we have
received TV calls IBV calls and
we do you refer them to the LA
LGBT centre. But I've gained so
much our knowledge today. So
I'm so happy that I can- refer
them to other people. It might
be close there are might be
more willing to help very.
Interested in helping- some of
the things we deal with are
mostly about accessibility- so
we often find. That people are
worried about the legal
definitions of domestic
violence. The violence that has
been perpetrated upon them. The
considered sick Rylance they're
worried about being outed to
their family or to their
employer- there are a lot. Of
survivors so many people do not
talk about it that are LGBT Q.
they are survivors of TV IPV.
And often times. Women in
particular on face higher DV
and IV V. and they are
instances of death- so they're
not a lot of survivors and even
in instances like- last April-
twenty eighteen. Lease teenage
couple and a money California-
they had an instance of DVD and
one of them instead of the
other to death. And there was
another incident it's not far
from there care where it is
right now but another it was
another gay couple and one of
them was killed in the
altercation. And so that kind
of ship the community and
thereof approached us and asked
us to give more- programs on
those sorts of things so right
now we have up your support
groups. Are per support groups
are. Have a game night which is
considered a pre support group-
it's for all people under the
LGBT Q. umbrella we have. A non
binary your support group a
grief. Your support group a
transcript of workgroup. And
amends for support group in a
women's for support group- so
right now the mostly focus on
like meeting together and going
through like a grieving process
other. We also have like from
those- the people that have
grown and have. Got what they
need they needed to get out of
our per support programs. They
started social groups and so
they're able to connect with
the community and that's really
what we as- a kid like a
community center there. Thank
you in- I'm going to ask on the
same question any additional
barriers aside from many
because we all know that that's
the number one- barrier for us
to be able to support by what
other barriers- or state my are
facing the LGBT. Community I
know we talked a little bit
about you know just a
culturally- it's you know it's
a stigma just in itself but
what other- issues do you see
that are facing the LGBT. One
of the barriers that we've-
recently for and was that a lot
of the programs are located in.
The city of Los Angeles- as
being in the San Gabriel Valley
and- a lot of our clients do
not have transportation and
that's a barrier. On it's very
difficult for them to access a
lot of the I'm services that
would specialized with the LGBT
Q. Q. plus community. And so-
for us specifically we are
always looking to branch out
and act I know that we have-
with. Some of the agencies
locally but- when we look.
Thank you for. Today all this
is a- close down- it it's
difficult when. It's not local
if it's an ongoing service such
as mental health services that
would be for example weekly
appointment and every week the
client would have to figure out
how to get and if it's in the
middle the Los Angeles it is a
commute from here. Thank you.
Also a lot of the barriers not
only that we face. Through the
RGB TQ it's a lot of
homelessness. Specifically the
trans women because once-
before their transition or what
the this type of transition
when they come out to their
parents and tell them- this is
the way I feel. I'm now G. B.
T. or K. or transitioning what
are they doing instead of being
support at what they do they
throw money to the street. At a
younger age in nowadays the
trans coming up younger younger
so what we need to do is try to
educate the parents. Because
not only by throwing their
children into the street that
could lead to more trauma
drugs. Sex work. And
incarcerations and on top of
that. For education so not only
are they being bullied through
school but. They have to do
what they have to do in order
to survive and the next thing
you know they wind up in in
jail and imprisoned in there.
Nothing out there so what I ask
is this how to do something to
educate the parents. To learn
how to stand by their siblings.
Because that that's the reason
why there's a lot of
homelessness within the LGBT
community. And also along. This
try to work on funding to
empower. Not only is
specifically the kinds
community. Hello also a lot of
the LGBTQ communities. Because
for employment. Because a lot
of people does not a lot of
places I'm sorry a lot
employers does not want to
hire. LGBT Q. or trans
community just because. Trance
our community members they have
higher education degrees but
was holding them back it's-
just be who they are and they
have all the qualifications.
That's what I advocate a lot
and- working with the
transgender advisory board. We
focus on and a lot of the
challenges that the community
our face the and in one of them
is the homelessness and
employment. Well thank you very
much if you have any additional
comments but I the competition
is important again you know we
talked about- language barriers
and in this case we're talking
about just barriers you know
just the mobile- barriers and I
completely understand that was-
why made that comment earlier
about you know the Latino
Hispanic community- if you will
come out you know the first
thing. Is disown you and you
know as a parent I have a
twelve year old and in the
world and I always wonder how
is that I can love my children
so much. Like when they were
born I just love them so much
bye bye- the minute you say
something like I a M. you know.
Transgender out to be two then
all of a sudden you the
supplement it never on the.
Ballot I think the vision for
the. Because they're still your
children. Now I am again. As a
mom you know I'm speaking as a
mother because I cannot see how
I can love them so much and
then they- tell me something I
don't want to hear. And then
can disown a child so the
education for parents I think
it's important but you know of
course. We can only do so much
of the services for the LGBTQ
community- is there are
important and I. Also one to-
acknowledge that the home. This
issue because I do see that a
lot- for LG Q. teens not Mister
the adults that teens are the
ones that can't find. Homes are
couch surfing and never mind
trying to find employment- so
there's at age fighting between
thanks there's some statistics
between the ages of. Somewhere
like around thirteen fourteen
to eighteen that they don't
really feel supported- by any
of our programs and so I think
we need to do more to try and
address those issues- with the
kids and so hopefully we can-
start- ask. For some help with
the tools arms up. Education
and incorporate you know
because we're talking about
because you're right I'm a lot
of the issues- are. Different
but at the end of the day- you
know of being a sex workers
also it's- is by land right and
so. They get beat up so it may
not be intimate partner and the
sense of relationships but it's
still- being abused- because
they have no other choices all-
I want to thank you for that-
at this point I will. Open it
up if anybody. Wants. To come
state. I really would
appreciate it. When we can I am
not been talk from there. Can I
speak on yes absolutely. Down
with our parent education is
that it's often nine that line
next people when I feel and
that's I mean let you know that
the now but the exes- gender
neutral marker so it's not that
the Lennox community is. More
homophobic another communities
I don't I don't want that to be
like a source of confusion-
there is a huge clear line X.
community and they're very open
and they're very welcoming-
it's just that a lot of times
Lennix people tend to be very
religious and religion is very
hopeful. Right I'm- not
necessary early. Next makes
them more home. As for the five
take. It just so happens that
that's kind of the way it turns
right we find many many line
experience that are. So willing
and- one hundred percent. Into
are you supporting their
children when they come to our
youth groups right when I think
thank you for clarification I
think that is true. And now we
have. There is light- father
Michael Griffin Johnson Baldwin
park that is very open to
supporting- communities he
doesn't care about you know
what date and finance and he
sees. Our people as people and
I think that that message needs
to get across that no matter
what it is or who you you you
are- the support as- well
needed and we're still human
beings and I. I wanna send shot
out to father Mike because he
he has partner I'm not only
with- the city of bottom park
but with all of us. In to. Be
open about- that he truly
believe that we're all children
of god and it doesn't matter
you know what we identify it
god if. We believe in god that
and we're supposed to be
supporting. Each other but
thank you the clarification.
Any. Yes also monitor share on
part of my story and I could I
totally- connect with which is
that earlier about- is Tony
I've been this inherit it and
also based on what she said
based on religion- to begin
with- my mother- I transition
at the age of six sixteen years
old. US of a topic graduated
from high school I was over the
limit of the trans gender male
nature on. The one and by the
way. And my era was the
eighties so the eighties era
was very difficult not only at
the aids epidemic- I did want
to have to do to survive not
only based on my education but
then could not in I guess I was
blessed. That even though I
did. A lot of sex work that's
why advocate a lot of it
because I've been there I
walked in their shoes. And I
know what it's like to be in
their shoes- not only what they
have become a hate crime but
they've got that on your- neck.
Update all the years I've
started doing that. I was also
an escort for over ten years I
did what I have to do to you to
make my aunt's me I travel to
the whole United States making
a lot of money I'm would deny
what I did because- being. And
I'm not ashamed of it because.
Doing the things that I did in
the past. That's what makes me
the person that I am now. To
advocate and to look. For my
community or my other siblings
and. And like when my father
passed away in the year two
thousand I already knew he
passed away a belt hammer thing
partners is disease so through
that. One wasn't able to
recognize why was I realized
that I lost my father. And my
father loved to meet my father
never laid a hand that me on
the contrary he encouraged me
to get higher education.
Because he said I already know
the path you're heading so I
advise you to try to get as
much education as you can
because that's the only in this
one empower you and left you.
Because the government can take
your material things the way
you might wind up in chaplain
president xterra but one thing
they can. Never take away from
you is your knowledge. And
through that I was blessed to
live in and to have a father
like that and once he passed
away right away I really knew
was going to inherit it in my
mother disinherited means not
only for the simple fact of
being why am. And learned to
improper myself and like I told
her you live your life I live
my life I won lift my truth we
only live one. And. It's up to
you but if you accept that or a-
get but I'm not going to be
miserable while you being
happy. So with that we just
live my truth and just let me
be white one. So and also on
top of that- we had a very
wonderful successful program.
That was funded by the federal
government which is found for
grant which was one of our
biggest grant. Fourteen Johnson
are seeking safety pro. And
they're seeking safety program.
It was supposed to be for three
years we started late but
within the two years that we
have that program we named it
project work have you E. R. K.
which it stands for working in
power it resilient and
knowledgeable. And it was only
for transgender women of color
if we have been living in or
experiencing trauma high risk
for HIV and aids and drug and
alcohol abuse. I raise the bar
as the FAP because a lot of
organizations we have had.
Grant in that program. A three
year grant they were able to.
Get twenty thirty individuals
to finish and graduate program.
I raise the bar and I had over
two hundred individuals
graduate my congratulations.
And after they would graduate
from my program not only with
the receipt a certificate. And
a certificate. Opened up
employment opportunities for a
lot of mine. Graduates for HIV
and aids counselling and role
in all. And en even though a
lot of them were undocumented
and the successfully completed
at they were able to use that
to get political five. Thank
you. Thank you and with that
dumb if there's no other
questions or comments- I want
to thank you again for your
participation in really-
hopefully we can- do what we
talked about as being more
awareness to domestic violence
yes. Such. I guess some
detective Paula and so it it
officer Rodriguez I am maybe I
got a little lost so. Domestic
abuse is that considered.
Demeanor a felony I got a
little lost with the
terminology I'm sorry. Well I
can try and- help but it
depends on the on the fence and
officer gas. Please I'm sorry.
The difference there's two
differences of misdemeanors
where there is no visible
injuries and up Allen is where
there is visible injuries so
the that's what differentiates
those. That's basically it.
Okay
. And I heard and no longer.
They have a cell phone. People
are. Well. The mystic violence
Los okay. Thank you and thank
you for that question because
it is important to- add to
differentiate and I think- I
officer how may have mentioned
that sometimes you know the
person that bad instigates the
fight doesn't necessarily
always become- the person that-
is held responsible because you
know obviously we all are no.
That some of these
relationships they knew which
by as to push and so they start
instigating so that they can
get some reaction and that's
how people get in trouble. But
I think you know the fact is
that they've been doing this
for a while at this not the
first offense and as as you
stated that he not ex what
times said before somebody
actually decides to leave cell
throw those are those both
times they may be you know a
few years it may be twenty
something you before the- the
fact is that you already know
how to get to them and the
dynamics have already been
built. You instigate- in order
to get you know whatever
reaction so I think important-
in terms of detectors five
posted this on my Facebook page
are. Fast so you by check on
some file on this server. No
Sir I. The for posting it is-
somebody on my pages saying
that I'm only focusing. I'm
victims what about those that
have been falsely accused now I
I'm not going to respond
because it'll be a long little
conversation- but I think the
problem is that- yes there
there are instances of you know
accusing. Others and not
necessarily having enough
evidence to prosecute but the
fact of the matter is that I
need to we need to focus on on
what's happening now the
statistics are are.
Overwhelming that we have so
many people that are victims of
domestic violence at all as you
know the victims have abusers
and so there's Tom on both
sides it's not just the
domestic violence victim but
the abuser the aggressor also
has to aye and so we're
dealing. Is that we get a
handle on letter don't try to.
Figure out who's being accused
of falsely etcetera etcetera so
you know there's only so much
that we are capable of doing
but what they did I'm made it a
night I'm sure it does- senator
Susan ruby is also committed to
trying to at least make. Some
make some headway and assist
programs. I'm hoping that.
Where where is the- believe
transit into getting more more
funding from the state so again
I want to thank you for your
participation if you have any
other questions my staff is
available I'm available but the
folks are here with resources
are available to at minimum
exchange cards so that we on
the that can leave here and
know who to call if we need
something which is a sense or
whatever it may be. So thank
you again for partisan in again
thank you the to the city of
Covina for hosting us and- I
think we will- go ahead- see-
yes so we have a resource for
outside- you know we have some
some of the folks that are
providing some resources but
other than thank you again and
looks. Continuing the chin and
again once we legislative.
Because of you. To help me. I'm
will be an option and if we
can. You know make some
positive steps I think that's a
victory for all of our
community so thank you